네 안녕하세요 빌사남 제가 오늘은
연말에 항상 저희가 이제 계획 같은
거를 말씀을 드리는데 2024년
bsn이 어떤 사업 방향으로 갈지 어
제가 영상을 좀 찍어 보려고 합니다
어 bsn 여러 사업들을 좀 많이
하고 있는데 저는 24년뿐만 아니라
정말 25년도 좀 폭발적으로 성장할
수 있는 해라고 생각합니다 24년을
그 어느 때보다 되게 준비도 열심히
할 거고 되게 여러 가지 시도를 할
예정인데 제 제가 어떤 좀 계획들을
가지고 있는지 여러분들한테
말씀드리도록 하겠습니다 어 우선
bsn 부동산 중개법인이 있습니다
그래서 지금 빌딩이란 고급 주택을
진행하고 있고 지금 청단 본점이랑
그다음 이제 해운대 부산 지점 그리고
저희가 이제 해외 이제 뉴욕이라는
도쿄 그리고 이제 중국 시장도 생각은
하고 있어요 중계와 관련해서는 뭐
해외도 좀 생각을 하고 있고 지금
당장 뭐 시장이 좋지 않지만 나중에
뭐 시장 시장이 좋아졌을 때는 여기
계신 분들이 해외에 투자할 수 있고
아니면 해외에 계신 분들이 우리나라에
투자할 수 있다라고 생각을 하기
때문에 좀 여러 방면으로 좀 많이
열어둘 생각이고 bsm 부동산
중개법인은 다른 회사랑 좀 다른 점은
대부분이 다 공인 중개사입니다 보통은
중개 보조원 분들이 되게 많아요이
bsn 부동산 중개법인은 다 이제
공인중개사로 되어 있게 진행을 하고
나중에 문제가 생겼을 때도 책임
소재라는 신뢰가 있는 중계를 하기
위해서 방향이 돼 있습니다 부동산
중개법인은 좀 그렇게 진행이 될 거
같고 그리고 빌딩 관리 파트도 좀
많이 키울 생각이에요 그래서 그전에는
사실 빌딩 관리가 그렇게 크진 않다가
올해부터 좀 정상화가 됐어요 그래서
실제로 수주한 것도 좀 많아졌고
앞으로 뭐 이런 빌딩 관리 업체에서도
업계에서도 확장을 많이 할 생각입니다
그리고 건축사 사무소도 있는데 건축사
사무소도 이제 수주 이런게 좀
작년보다 많지 않았지만 좀 꾸준히
수주하고 있고 최근에는 해운대구에
있는 건물을 수주 했거든요 해운
대구라 좀 전국적으로 이렇게 뭔가
설계할 수 있는 기회들을 많이
만들려고 하고 있습니다 그리고 bsn
건설도 있는데 최근에 건설업계가 좀
매우 안 좋아요 얼마 전 기사를
보니까 하루에 하나씩 망하고 있다 뭐
이런 기사를 봤었는데 다행히 bsn
건설은 작년보다 거의 한 뭐 1.5배
정도 더 수주를 했어요 지금 대출도
없고 지금 공사 현장도 한 열군데
지금 동시에 진행하고 있는데 뭐 없이
잘 진행하고 있습니다 24년이나
25년 도에 건설 부분도 더 많이
키울 생각이고요 저는
공인중개사이의신청
있을 때 그런 필요한 것들 있잖아요
대부분 다 모르세요 뭐 인테리어라던지
사무시 계합할 때라든지 뭐 그런
것들을 모아서 중개사들은 위한 뭔가
그런 걸 좀 하고 싶어요 요즘
스타일에 맞는 중개 사무소 뭔가
인테리어 중개사들이 쓸 만한 뭐 매물
관리 프로그램 그런 것부터 시작해
가지고 중개사들은 위한 그런 거를
하고 싶고 저는 어찌 됐든 우리나라가
중개사에 대한 인식이 너무 안 좋기
때문에이 업에 대한 위상도 올리고
싶고 중개사들이 좀 이렇게 발전한
것도 좀 기어도 하고 싶거든요 중개사
업계에 대한 사업적인 부분도 좀
생각을 하고 있습니다 더 나아가서는
뭐 시행도 할 생각이에요 어찌됐든
지금 분위기가 매우 안 좋긴 하지만
또 시장이 괜찮아질 시기가 오긴
하거든요 그래서 24년도 25년도이
시행 할만한 부지를 매입하지 않을까
예상을 해 봅니다서 제가 시행하고
싶은 거는 소규모 주택 아니면 이런
건물들이 아니라 초고가 주택을 하고
싶어요 청담동에 있는 그런 초고가
주택 아니면 한남동에 있는 초고가
주택을 짓고 싶습니다 그런 시행 같은
것도 장기적으로는 생각을 하고 있고
그리고 제가 공간 사업에도 관심이
많아요 지금 워낙 공실이 많기 때문에
저희가 그 공간을 채워 줄 수 있을
만한 그런 컨텐츠를 좀 생각을 하고
있습니다 아마 내년에 조금 시도를 할
수 있을 것 같아요 일단 소규모로
한번 시작을 해도 인원을 채용해서
하는 거보다는 진짜 무인으로 할
만한데 무인으로 할 만한 그런
업종들을 가지고 내년에 테스트를 해
보지 않을까 그래서 진짜 괜찮으면
저희가 중계도 하고 설계도 하고
공사도 하고 거기 이제 임차 들어가고
이런 식으로 진행이 가능할 것
같습니다 그래서 공간에 대한 그런
사업도 좀 생각해 보고 있고 그리고
제가 엔터테인먼트 회사가 설립이 돼
있어요 그래서 제가 올해 어 초에
설립을 했는데 웹드라마 제작한 거를
보신 분도 계실 거예요 그래서 매년
기획해 가지고 제작을 하고 싶어요
1회 1회 정도라도 부동산 콘텐츠가
너무 없잖아요 우리나라에 부동산
콘텐츠 제작에 그래도 좀 생각이
있습니다 중계 업체에 대한 뭔가 그런
스토리 웹
드라마라지만 싶고 그리고 회사 내
이렇게 소속 중계사 분들을 연예인처럼
어 이렇게 좀 키워 주고 싶은 생각도
좀 있고요 엔터테인먼트 사업도 좀
계속할 예정이고 그리고 저
개인적으로는 저희 bsn 도움이 될
거 같다라는 업체를 투자를 하거나
매입하고 싶 m& 할 생각도 있어요
업체들도 좀 계속 보다가 기회들이
생기면 투자나 아니면 &를 할 생각도
있습니다 마지막으로 내년 한 3
4월쯤에 매거진이 나와요 부동산
매거진이 나오는데 그거를 토대로 좀
정기적으로 매거진도 좀 발행하면서
부동산 중개사들이 볼 만한 주제를
많이 넣고 그 더 나아가서는 부동산
관련 신문사도 설립하고 싶 은 생각도
있습니다 그렇게 좀 방향이 정해져
있고 지금 해야 될게 너무 많네요네
너무 많은데 부동산과 관련된 거는
저는 일단은 다 해야 된다라고
생각하고 우리 업이 관련돼 있는 거는
최대한 할 수 있는 거는 다 해야
된다라고 생각합니다 그래서 뭐가
어떻게 될지 몰라요 근데 이제이
전제는 무리하게 하진 않습니다 진짜
감당이 가능할 정도의 신규 사업을
하는 거지 뭐 예를 들어서 뭐 시행을
하는데 부지를 뭐 진짜 영끌해서 사
가지고 무리하게 한다 그런 건 안
합니다이 신규 사업이라는 건 본업에
집중을 하고 본업에서 수익이
안정적으로 발생될 때 무리하지 않은
선에서 하는 거지 본업을 대치고 뭔가
신규 사업만 하면 나중에 큰 문제가
생길 수 있습니다 본업은 본업대로
하고 붙일 수 있는 건 계속 좀
붙이고 제가 말씀드렸던 거를 좀
2024년도 25년도 좀 할 계획이고
저는 어떻게 보면 bsn 좀 선장
같은 느낌이에요 그래서 제가 어떻게
방향을 정하는지에 따라서 많이
달라지고 합니다 책임감도 있고 좀
어떻게 가야 될지 매일같이 고민하고
매일같이 생각을 합니다 그래서 물론
제가 말씀드리는 거에서 다 이룰 순
없습니다 좀 수정 보안이 될 수도
있지만 계속 도전하고 시도하고 수정
보안에 가면서 이제 성장을 하는 거지
그냥 나는 그냥 중계 사니까 그냥
중계만 할 거야 하면은 나중에 10년
뒤 20년 뒤 그 이상에 뭔가 변화는
많이 없을 거 같아요 해외 진출도 막
생각하는게 과연 10년 뒤 20년
년뒤 30년 뒤에도 이렇게 국내에서
이렇게 하고 있을 거냐 생각하면 또
물음표거꾸로
한창이에요 한창 아직 뭐 30대
초반이기 때문에 진짜 10년뒤 20년
뒤를 생각하고 지금 도전하는 거기
때문에 나중에 어떻게 될지 모르겠지만
계속 수 정보 하나 하면서 목표랑
계획을 도전해 보도록 하겠습니다 어
일단은 영상은 여기까지 하고요 전에
영상들도 제가 계획한 것들 좀 보면은
다 못 이룬 것도 있고 일부 이런
것도 있고 하긴 하지만 계속 이제
도전하려고 하면 그래도 조금은
성장했다 렇게 저는 생각을 합니다
내년이 매우 기대가 되고이 사업
자체가 저는 워낙 너무 재밌고이
bsn 창업하는 예상 나중에 진짜 뭐
상장도 하고 싶고 그리고 저도 이게
진짜 글로벌 기업을 만들고 싶은 그런
야망도 있고 저도 나중에 10년대
20년대 어떻게 될지 되게 궁금합니다
근데 그렇게 변화하려면 계속 이렇게
뭘 도전하고 끊임없이 이렇게 하는게
원동력이라고 생각을 하기 때문에 제
계획이랑 목표를 말씀을 드렸습니다
그래서 어이 영상이 아마 업데이트될
쯤이면 2024년 1월 1일일 겁니다
여러분들 새해복 많이 받으시고
2024년 1월 1일이 저희 bsn
창업한지 8년이 벌써
8년 8년이 8년네 여러분들 새해복
많이 받으시고
2024년에는 늘 몸 건강하시고 좀
원하시는 바 다 이루셨으면 좋겠습니다
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다
감사합니다 l